[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari sol i'm a
pianist composer and today i want to
talk about an approach to practicing
standard repertoire or any kind of piece
of music or technique that i've been
thinking a lot about recently
[Music]
the basic concept is to compose or
improvise little excerpts that really
complement and encourage the act of
repetition which is of course very
necessary for practicing
let me explain using this example of a
passage from mephisto waltz number one
by franz lisz that i recently revisited
as you'll see it wasn't going so well
[Music]
now in order to improve how i play it i
need to do two things i need to
understand it in a way that really
serves how i play it and also put in the
reps to really get a hold of it so when
i was studying this passage i was quite
frustrated because i didn't really know
how to practice it
and i would ask my teacher
about ways to practice it and i remember
him telling me practice this until your
face turns blue
and then he gave me another tip which
was to use
[Music]
shadow
practicing which is to get
to note the destination note
[Music]
before you play it in a very fast manner
and that's very effective too but it
didn't really take me that far
and also i wasn't super motivated to
practice the section so i just remember
going back to my practice room and being
a little lost and i practiced it you
know dozens of times
and it didn't get very good
for the understanding part of it i
simplified what's going on in the right
hand to isolate the technique being used
which is a single note plus an octave of
the same pitch right above it
so my plan is to become comfortable
playing this technique
playing this kind of
pattern starting from different notes
and different transitions
so with that in mind looking at the
first measure of this section i'm
focusing on just the pitches
and with a a sharp d sharp
this pattern is applied
[Music]
now this may seem obvious but at the
time when i was practicing this passage
i didn't really think about the
formation of these notes i just focused
on
i guess practicing this until my face
turned blue
and i would just repeat it over and over
and over again
for the repetitions part i found that
simply repeating that phrase or even a
beat in its original form gets really
boring frustrating and gives me anxiety
so my solution to that is to set up a
little environment around each thing i'm
trying to work on that makes it very
inviting natural and some degree
pleasant to repeat what i'm trying to
practice
[Music]
it's sort of like
functional looping and functional
minimalism
[Laughter]
[Music]
so here are some more examples of that
[Music]
so i find this approach not only
effective but really fun to do and it's
something that i'd like to continue to
talk about and demonstrate in these
practice notes videos because i really
believe that practicing can be
extremely interesting and not
necessarily dull and boring and robotic
even for things that require a ton of
repetition
[Applause]
[Music]
so i filmed myself every time i spent
time on this in the last couple of days
to keep track of exactly how much i was
doing and i had a little less than an
hour of footage
so obviously i was revisiting this
passage so i had a bit of an advantage
but still it's worth noting how i went
from point a to point b
[Music]
so anyway i hope you found that helpful
let me know in the comments below what
are some passages that you're currently
struggling with or having difficulty
grasping
and i'll see you in the next video bye
let's find that spot
all the memories
the memories yes the memories